all right thanks very much for dick for
agreeing to do this interview and
welcome and thank you all for being here
my name is Samuel Kohler I am a
professor of computer science at
University of Maryland and my
association with dick carp goes long
before I first met him almost 32 years
ago he published his Turing Award
lecture called combinatorics complexity
and randomness and that was one of those
rare moments in my life that suddenly my
own future became clear to me and I was
greatly inspired by Dick's during a
world lecture and I ended up went to
Cornell to pursue a PhD in algorithms
actually working with one of Dick's
collaborators and friends Vijay was
Ronnie who was my thesis advisor I was
very fortunate to be advised by him
after that I moved University of
Maryland where I've been on the faculty
dick Karp is a giant in the field and
it's known to all of us but I just
wanted to maybe mention a few of his
awards and accomplishments he won the
Turing Award as I mentioned earlier in
the mid-80s and subsequently won the
National Medal of Science his remember
the National Academies won the Kyoto
prize the Ben Franklin prize and has
really been a thought leader in our
field so I'm really honored and humbled
that you agreed to do this interview
with me I think you have been a pioneer
in the field and have led you know
theory computer science at UC Berkeley
for almost starting next year will be
five decades since you've been here and
I thought this would be a very good time
to do an interview where you're almost
finishing 50 years of your career at
Berkeley and also stepping down as
director of the Institute which is
really an amazing amazing place I had
good fortune to be here for a few weeks
on sabbatical and so I wanted to take
this time maybe to ask you a few
questions and the same way that your
turing award lecture inspired me I'm
hoping that some of your answers will
inspire other young people in the field
and I know all my students are excitedly
looking forward to this interview and
and listening to your answers because
they have been reading your work and
learning about your algorithmic work in
the 70s and 80s through the classes that
I teach so thank you very much for
agreeing to do this
my first question has to do
you spent several decades at UC Berkeley
leading the field of theoretical
computer science what are the big
changes that you have witnessed because
you've been through the whole birth of
the field today well if I can take it
back to my graduate studies I was a
graduate student at Harvard in late 50s
in the computation lab and at that time
the term computer science had not been
coined there was an organization ACM the
Association for Computing Machinery that
already existed but although computer
science really had had not been
identified as a field of study there
were many sources of what became
computer science the sources came from
numerical analysis from operations
research from Electrical Engineering
from mathematics we knew about touring
and Shannon and and Newman and other
other founders but computer science was
really not organized as a as a
discipline theoretical computer science
began to take shape in the early 60s I
would say and that was also the time
when computer saying science departments
came into existence and the topics at
that time were ranged from switching
theory and finite automata we knew about
Raven and Scott and we knew about
digital design compiler design and
formal languages were studied as I
mentioned numerical analysis but most of
the branches of computer science that we
now study really hadn't been identified
there was no cryptography cryptography
really came along in the 70s there was
certainly no quantum computing the
notion of looking for connections
between
computer science theory of computer
science and various scientific fields
really hadn't come about it was really
around the turn of the century around
2000 that we began and under the
designation of the computational lens we
began looking at connections between
theoretical computer science and fields
like physics the early days of
theoretical computer science thus say
starting in the in the 60s the problems
usually arose in a practical context and
where rather natural and relatively
simple problem problems sorting
searching basic search in a graph
arithmetic processes things that really
had a wide roll and and we're natural
Exedy theory developed in a strange way
we knew about Turing machines but the
work on computational complexity took a
strange direction in the early 60s
instead of studying computation in full
generality we tended to look at
handicapped computers computers that had
only two tapes or two heads or operated
on a stack we're limited in some way and
they define certain classes of language
languages but the idea notions related
to combinatorial explosions polynomial
time really were not current with the
theoreticians of that period the heart
Manas turns paper in 1965 introduced
some of those notions
edmonds and operations research was also
very influential and so the field
changed the P versus NP question came
came about and as I mentioned over time
all of these other sub fields have
become prominent photography in the
seventies and early eighties and then
other areas like interactive proofs the
role of randomness was recognized
probably in the 70s people started
thinking about randomized algorithms and
in general the field has branched out so
that the bodies of knowledge the
frontiers are quite extensive in many of
the sub areas of theoretical computer
science so whereas in the early days we
could sort of pick up problems off the
ground we just asked look over the
shoulder of any programmer and we a she
or he can use a search tree and so forth
the there's been a tendency to make
things much more mathematical I think
one aspect of this is that many people
who would have gone into pure
mathematics in the earlier stages and
how quite powerful mathematically and
applying it through the theoretical
computer science and each of these sub
areas has itself become a substantial
body of knowledge so you can't just
one follow-up question do something that
you said earlier so do you think it's
possible that in the late 50s people
were thinking that these constraint
machines might be easier to build or
they might be easier to program or they
might be a lot faster when specialized
hardware comes up and that's why they
were trying to understand what the power
of those machines no I think was just a
game well if it had any practical
motivation it probably came from
linguistics where I said Chomsky and
others were trying to created the
Chomsky hierarchy and were interested in
various mechanisms of language structure
that could be modeled by machines
context-free languages for example so I
think that was the the motivation rather
than the idea that you could you know
that you could build machines with two
tapes machines with many tapes but also
today computer being a computer
scientist is well understood and society
is what that means yeah was that a
strange term to label yourself as in the
50s we should tell somebody I am a
computer scientist I don't think I use
that term well my mother told me that I
was that I should go into the field of
data processing because it was really
going to be big and so that was good
advice yeah so I thought of myself as
being in data processing I was also very
attracted to operations research which
was a hot field in the in the already in
the 50s and I read the works of
Fulkerson and dancing and people like
that and that was I saw opportunities
for myself there I'd like to screen
mathematics then I could see many things
that could be done so if you asked me
what I was I would have probably said
that I was in operations research or in
data processing okay also what do you
think were the main contributions of
terrible computer science in the last 50
years if you had to highlight the last
50 years
well I think I'd like to focus on the
maybe on the Lifetime movies the Simon's
okay talk about that so I think there
are a number of threads that have come
about over the last several years the
spectral graph theory and and related
areas of linear algebra have proved to
be incredibly important and led to new
algorithms for old problems I remember
some time ago my friend Gary Miller told
me that that the best way to solve
Network flow problems was through linear
algebra and I told him it was crazy
because of obviously the best way to
solve flow problems was to push flow
right one path at a time through the
network he was right I was wrong so that
that's been a very powerful development
cryptography has become more and more
relevant especially with computing in
the cloud and delegation of
responsibility to other agents and
multi-party communication that that's a
very deep and exciting area the
connections with the Natural Sciences
mechanism design in economics
connections with genomics and molecular
biology
I think connections of computation to
the the study of computation in the
brain is emerging although we really
still know very little so and of course
the whole machine learning data science
development it seems that nowadays you
can become a millionaire by announcing
that you're a data scientist and getting
multiple offers right right companies
who think that if you
if they could only hire somebody imbued
with artificial intelligence that that
person could sprinkle it over all of
their concerns and make the company
successful so so the data science Big
Data artificial intelligence Direction
is extremely important parallel
computation was quite important in the
in the 80s I think there was a lot of
work on parallel right and that seems to
have faded but I expect that it will be
making a comeback because it's really so
terribly relevant so I believe it's may
be diminished in the theory community
but actually the multi-core processing
is still a very big topic that's right
within architecture and so on right so
yes that's true but it hasn't been
accompanied by a corresponding hominid
portion of theoretical size it seems to
be that that's overdue I expect that new
directions and cryptography will keep
coming up lattice based cryptography is
interesting because lattice based
methods may even surpass what a quantum
computer can do us and they don't depend
on factoring but the directions that
will be taken will depend a lot on the
initiatives of people who just decide to
start programs like the Simons program
yeah so changing gears slightly let me
ask another question so you had an
exceptionally successful career if you
had to think back to the days when you
were both an undergraduate student
appears you shouldn't were there any
special qualities that you think you
focused on that were in the long run had
a big payoff well I sort of wasted my
time as a graduate student I should have
spent worth time learning various
branches of mathematics so there are
certain very relevant fields of
mathematics where my knowledge is shaky
and therefore condemned to work on
fairly simple intuitive questions for
the most part I think the term the most
important experience
as I had in my student days we were
first of all finding out that I was
really good at probability discrete
probability and probabilistic reasoning
and I had a feeling for probability and
statistics and other branches of
operations research
my grades were mediocre because I didn't
work on my courses off because they
didn't seem to be I didn't quite
understand why applied complex analysis
was going to be important in our career
but I had some summer jobs where I was
able to contribute and that led to my
have through a growing feeling of of
confidence so I would say that my
graduate career was exciting because we
could certainly see the looming
importance of what we were doing but was
somewhat defective in terms of concrete
learning I could have done I could have
done more however I was lucky and in
landing a job at IBM Research because
there I could work under more
experienced scientists and really sort
of develop my expertise and I had the
opportunity to work with Michael Rabin
who visited the IBM lab and Allan
Hoffman you may or may not know he did a
lot of work in circulation circulation
flows in linear algebra and spectral
graph theory and he was a model for me
and there were other excellent
colleagues like Shmuel Winograd and
out of Rosenberg so I was lucky to get
that job at IBM
so that relates to my next question
actually so you spent almost a decade at
IBM how do you think your life might
have been different had you just stayed
there after after 1968 well if I just if
I had just stayed there first of all I
should say that I loved my job at IBM
this the 60s when I was at IBM were a
period where the company was ascendant
it had 75% of the computer market and so
they could afford to give some of us the
luxury of just working on whatever we
wanted to do so it was it was a perfect
job for me and I left only because I
thought that my social life and
involvement in radical causes could be
enhanced by coming to Berkeley and so I
seeked Westchester County at 17 from New
York but if I had stayed first of all I
would have had to retire at 65 because
they sort of booted everybody out at my
age so I've managed to continue 283
since the university doesn't have that's
fortunate for us fortunate for me at
least as well I think all of these
industrial paradises like bill labs and
IBM and Microsoft Research and so on
have their ups and downs and so you
can't really count on an extended career
where you have the freedom to follow
your curiosity I think nowadays very few
places where you can just dream your
dreams without being limited to
short-term objectives that seems to be
the way it's going in industry so as a
flipside to that I would argue that
maybe for some researchers being in an
industrial lab setting actually allows
them to be in a sense closer to the
problems that people are running into
and in academia you're slightly to move
from
that especially as a theoretician right
so yeah this is true I think it depends
on the individuals attitude and and
initiative so even that IBM I think we
were somewhat cloistered in the
mathematical sciences the part I see I
see but I but we we definitely had
connections with what the company was
doing in particular it was an
extraordinary person named John Kok who
won the Turing Award for his work on
computer architecture who spends his
time just wandering around the lab like
Johnny Appleseed taking ideas from one
place and planting them in another and
so he would usually around the time I
was getting ready to go home in the
evening he would drop by and bend my ear
for half an hour about his latest ideas
about compilers that's wonderful to hear
so he was the same person watching who
was instrumental in designing several
chips and architectures at IBM correct
yeah that's correct yeah there was that
awareness I probably didn't explain it
as much as I might have but it was there
so I guess my next question also relates
to the move to an academic environment
compared to being in an industrial lab
so I'm sure you are incredibly proud of
all of the PhD students you've graduated
and in terms of the further impact that
their work has had but let me ask like
how do you sort of decide between
weighing your time between working very
closely with students versus thinking
deeply about one question on your own
which sometimes I know some people
prefer to just sit prefer to sit in
their office and spend 80% of the time
focusing on one problem that they care
deeply about and especially if it's a
very hard problem that it has been open
for decades sometimes it may not even
make sense to put a first year PhD
student to work on P versus NP but if
you want to work on it you have the
luxury to just spend your time so how do
you decide like and how you weigh your
time in well I wouldn't work on P versus
NP unless I have an idea how to do
something with it
and I don't I found it immensely
enjoyable to
have the opportunity to advise students
I've had more than 40 PhD students
including about 10 women about 10 of my
students have gone into computational
biology and many of them have done
better than I have done in that field
I'd like to interact and don't consider
myself such a deep fear improver that
long periods of isolation without human
contact would lead to very much I think
I've done better by first of all working
with people who are smarter than I am
and secondly working with enthusiastic
students in terms of directing students
I try I try to give suggestions but I
try not to dictate what they do I dunno
I think it's very important for them to
develop their own taste and emphasis and
I prefer it if they have a very large
voice in defining their own problem
beyond that I think some of them like to
spend their time interacting with other
students others have very deep ideas and
then and really have learned more from
them than they they learned from me
usually there's a period of pessimism
that comes over a student at some slow
period and his or her progress and I try
to get them over that and and ensure
them that it's that it's happened to me
and that it's normal and that if they
keep keep at it comes through to the
other end of the tunnel so actually I
think that's very valuable advice for
most of us or many people who are just
starting out as professors in the field
to learn how to advise students oh yeah
before that at any particular skills
that you focus on in developing or
instilling in your students I encourage
them to read to write to develop their
teaching skills to polish their ability
to present a coherent argument I also
often advised them to take on a
secondary interest other than theory and
most importantly not necessarily to work
on the most fashionable theory problem
of the day but to take into account
whether the problem they work on might
in the end actually have some impact on
the real world
computer science also has been building
many bridges with other scientific
fields in some computer science
departments I think there is some
tension between emphasis on core
computer science versus
interdisciplinary applications you have
any thoughts or advice for us on the
issue well first of all I'd say that
much of the interesting work going on
nowadays is interdisciplinary and any
university the traditional structures
within a university should not be a
deterrent through the formation of these
interplay the interdisciplinary
connections I know this is hard because
people get promoted by their departments
and many of the and the curricular
aspects of teaching are in all of the
everyday business of teaching run by
departments whereas for a field like
computational biology branches of it
like neuroscience or the study of
economic mechanisms you really need to
go
go beyond I think so each University
will have its own way of accommodating
the interdisciplinary studies but it's
important to be flexible and and not
that the standard change so chains of
command in the Universities deter people
from forming broad connections across
boundaries so I don't have any specific
organizational suggestions I think
that's a matter for the universities
each one has its own traditions given
the recent advances in AI there's an
ongoing debate about whether machines
are gonna take over the world and become
malicious is there any real danger of
that in the immediate future should we
worry about that what do you think I
think that I'm not worried about their
taking over the world I think that's
very far-fetched I see no evidence that
artificial intelligence in the sense of
a universal intelligence rather than one
that's very focused on a defined area
will occur so I just haven't seen it
seems that the achievements associated
with artificial intelligence are they've
always been on very stylized to find
problems defined by some somebody else
and any broader awareness that a
computer might have I just haven't seen
much evidence of that so just playing
computers don't know that they're
playing chess for example so I think the
the idea of computers being smarter than
we are is is very far-fetched I don't
expect to see that happening there and
there have been many incredible
surprises I must say though that I would
never have thought that compute
could play go better than the best human
player and and moreover learned to do it
by playing by by playing against
themselves and gradually improving that
that came as a shock to me so but I
don't really feel that the notion of
computers with broad intellectual and
intuitive capacities will come into
existence I just if at all it's going to
be well beyond my lifetime the same time
AI and machines are going to be decision
makers in the future well that's that's
where I think the true danger is I think
as we delegate decision-making to
computers whether it's you know
directing missiles to their targets or
more mundane things like
[Music]
issuing loans in a bank or China or
hiring people for jobs we tend to rely
on algorithms and lot of mated methods
and I think there are some very deep
intellectual issues that I hope you'll
study at this Institute about what it
means for a decision-making algorithm to
be fair what does it mean to be biased
what does it mean to be ethical what
does it mean to be socially responsible
and that's the area where we lean on
computers to land our airplanes and
issue our contracts and if we if we
yield the control to algorithms whose
properties we don't understand I think
we're heading for heading for trouble
this is related to the current
achievements in deep learning because
they are undoubtedly very
impressive for style that certain
stylized problems but we don't
understand how these you don't really
have a characterization or a clear or an
insight into what these neural networks
are doing and therefore how can we trust
them to perform the medical operation or
pilot an airplane precisely so three
weeks ago there was actually a workshop
in this room yeah where there was a lot
of interesting talks about adversarial
machine learning that I found
fascinating right exactly yeah that's
another area that will probably be
attacking here at the Institute so that
naturally leads to my last question so
the Simon's Institute obviously has been
a game changer for theory what do you
see happening here and how it's going to
shape the future of our field in the
next five years well I already mentioned
a few areas that I think will be coming
coming up we'll probably be doing more
on distributed and parallel computation
newer directions in cryptography quantum
will be coming up with some frequency
that's an incredibly important and
exciting area although we don't quite
know where it's going but really in in
running the Institute the challenge that
we've had is not having good topics we
have so many good topics to to pick from
it's really finding leaders in the field
who are willing to exert their energy to
organize the program and see it through
to the end so we're really in the hands
of the community and we so far in the
early days when we were just starting
most of the programs where Berkeley
centric we we relied on our immediate
colleagues to organize those programs
fortunately over the five years of our
existence the community the broad
community has come forward and we've
organizing teams that have taken the
responsibilities to run programs and and
the as I say there are so many appealing
areas and I think the the key issue is
whether people from the community will
continue stepping forward and see no
reason to doubt it so that's the end of
my question since we have an audience
here we have time for one quick question
from the members of the audience
the what advice would you have for young
faculty members who are starting off you
gave some excellent advice for students
first of all I applaud them for taking a
position where they're going to be torn
between teaching research administration
grant getting its in the first few years
of a faculty members career are very
demanding honey I am very lucky that I
had enough experience that IBM that I
would was able to come in with tenure
and I didn't have to go through the
anxiety of qualifying for tenure I would
say that it's a much harder existence
than they would have if they joined a
research division of a company and so
the compensation is if you love to teach
it's a pleasure to have a captive
audience and have the opportunity to do
that if you if you'd like to work with
young people of course this is the only
way I think that that even though you
know the end the hours are long long and
the responsibilities are heavy many
people who will want to do it because
nowadays you can't really have a
curiosity driven research program in a
company it used to be that places like
like Bell Labs and IBM gave people that
opportunity to sort of dictate their own
career and I I fear that those days are
over
and so if you go into a company nowadays
you can expect to be given that niche
related to the company's efforts some
people love that but if you if you want
to just dream your own dreams the only
way to do it is to be a faculty member
or perpetual graduate student no people
I mean at Google for example this going
to be on the record at Google I think
you have to work on the mainstream
concerns of the company now fortunately
but now people many people seem to love
being at Google and I guess the reason
is that the areas like advertising are
so broad and so multi-dimensional that
there are plenty of questions for them
so they're willing to restrict
themselves to such an area and of course
Google does have or alphabet which is
the parent company does have a lot of
efforts that have much more speculative
and that in that way it's I would say
that Google has been has increased
proportion of people who really can be
doing speculative things whereas most
companies have shrunk it are you worried
about those companies sucking up the
talent out of universities and putting
them into proprietary research where
they can't even publish and talk about
it
I haven't been worrying about it but now
that you pointed out yeah yeah right
yeah
yeah I see some of the best minds are
being drawn into into corporate
activities and robotics for example so
at the same time I'll add sometimes
these companies enable certain forms of
research and a tougher to do in academia
because I also think they have access to
tremendous computing resources which is
needed for these broad projects and
sitting as a professor you might not
have the funding to be able to do that
we are sitting at Google you could so
they're things that the company will
enable yeah happening yeah yeah that's a
good point and one of the selling points
for Google and that they emphasize is
that the decisions you make working for
Google on products will affect hundreds
of millions of people and that's very
powerful a very powerful argument
University it's less likely that you'll
be able to have that degree rightfulness
right yeah so in closing I'd like to
thank you again for agreeing to do this
I want to also take this opportunity to
thank the wonderful staff at the Symons
Institute that made this possible at
short notice so thanks thanks everyone
and thank you very much thank you very
much I've enjoyed it thank you
then we can continue doing questions off
the record after this interview Steve
okay thank you for coming
[Applause]